on tuesday may 24th 19 young children
and two adults were killed in a school
shooting in uvalde texas it took over 90
minutes to stop the shooter but it has
now been revealed that some police
officers breached the school to get
their own children out before
the shooter was taken down
[Music]
texas law enforcement officials have
changed their stories so many times i
wouldn't be surprised if we find out
they personally escorted the gunman into
the school this was the deadliest
american school shooting since the 2012
massacre at sandy hook elementary this
is the 27th school shooting this year we
have had 213 mass shootings in less than
six months of 2022. you don't need to be
enrolled in ron desantis school of
banned mathematics to know how bad these
numbers are the uvalde shooting happened
just 10 days after the horrific shooting
at the buffalo supermarket on may 14th
we unfortunately live in a country where
guns outnumber people and gun violence
has become an everyday occurrence the
correlation between the number of guns
in america and the number of gun-related
deaths in america is undeniable maybe
this slaughtering of innocent children
is a wake-up call for republicans they
are the pro-life party after all and
they've said on multiple occasions they
want to save the children i'm sure by
now texas senator ted cruz has offered a
solution one of the things that everyone
agreed is don't have all of these
unlocked back doors have one door into
and out of the school i'm sorry what was
that have one door into and out of the
school his solution to mass shootings is
one door i mean why stop there let's
make it a doggy door instead that's
small enough for children to fit through
you know for a brief moment i really
thought ted cruz was gonna be helpful
and then i remembered that ted cruz also
tried to ban dildos okay forget cancun
cruz let's try texas attorney general
ken paxton we need to continue to try to
focus on preventing this we we can't
stop bad people from doing bad things
they're going to violate murder laws
they're not going to follow gun lines
i've never understood that argument but
we are we can't harden these schools we
can
create points of access that are
difficult to get through we can
potentially arm and prepare and train
teachers and other administrators to
respond quickly because the reality is
we don't have the resources to to have
law enforcement at every school hold on
the gop who is notorious for banning
books and not giving teacher school
supplies wants to give teachers guns
instead giving teachers guns and placing
armed guards in schools does not protect
students from mass shootings in fact one
study found that schools with armed
guards were more likely to have a higher
death hold during a mass shooting but in
ken paxton's fantasy world a teacher
arrives on their first day at remington
rifle elementary and goes through their
classroom checklist construction paper
check erasers check nine millimeter
smith and wesson check and then of
course when that plan ultimately fails
arming those children that republicans
forced women to birth is their backup
plan cause nothing stops a bad guy with
a gun like a child with a gun and i can
see it now little timmy goes off to
school with his bulletproof backpack an
ar-15 in a toy story lunchbox full of
bullets i'm sorry but the fact that we
live in a country that assumes a random
civilian should risk their own life to
save another is incredibly deranged but
now that i think about it maybe we
shouldn't take advice from the guy
that's currently being investigated by
the fbi also how did this guy just win
his primary anyway why don't we just go
further up the leadership chain and try
texas governor greg abbott oh here's a
tweet from abbott where he talks about
gun ownership i'm embarrassed texas
number two in nation for new gun
purchases behind california
let's pick up the pace texans at nra
okay that's embarrassing i didn't fully
read the tweet until right now okay
here's a video of abbott signing gun
legislation in 2021 i'm sure this
prevents future shootings i'm signing
seven laws to protect second amendment
rights in the lone star state joined by
lieutenant governor dan patrick house
speaker david phelan several republican
lawmakers and members of the national
rifle association that new laws will
expand gun rights for texans the first
law he signed is what was being called
the constitutional carry bill which gets
rid of the licensing and training
requirement for texans who are 21 years
or older to carry a pistol those who
believe and support second amendment
rights we support the right of every
law-abiding american to be able to have
a weapon to defend themselves jesus
christ does any texas lawmaker actually
care about human life don't answer that
the sad truth is there have been eight
mass shootings in texas over the past 13
years all while lawmakers have steadily
loosened restrictions on carrying
firearms marjorie taylor green and every
other deplorable republican want to
point fingers and blame others like
they're just playing a game of clue i'm
sorry to ruin the game but it was not
professor woke in the library with crt
it was the gun it's always been the
[__] gun republicans love to blame
mental illness for mass shootings so if
it's such a problem like they say it is
then why haven't they done anything to
care for those suffering if it's such a
problem why did trump make it easier for
those with mental illness to get guns
when he rolled back an obama-era
regulation if it's such a problem why
didn't they say no i'll tell you why
it's because republicans don't care
about you or anyone else so when exactly
will republicans start carrying 500 mass
shootings per year 800 a thousand how
many more innocent lives have to die
because of some weird fetish that
republicans have with guns 90 percent of
americans support background checks on
gun purchases but republican politicians
they're holding our country hostage at
gunpoint we are tired of waiting we need
to vote these politicians out of office
because if we don't
they will continue to send their empty
thoughts and prayers and happily take
donations from the nra and speak at
their conventions just days after a mass
shooting where children were murdered
the time for gun reform is past due we
need to stand up and make our voices
heard a great example of this is when
beto o'rourke confronted greg abbott at
his conference for the uvalde mass
shooting excuse me
excuse me
[Music]
sir you're out of line
sir you are online i'm sure you are
outlined please leave this auditorium
so i leave you with this in a world of
greg abbott's
be a better or work
[Music]